o lado espiritual do que quem fala é o
dark diz muito bem vindos a mais bela e
o estrago de que o vídeo de software
lançou dois eps que me prende aqui um
vídeo que fazer uma guerra em casa mas
eu ainda tô arrasada material os jogos
os fatos essas coisas todas entretanto
vou ter que treinar a minha poderia nem
eu que está em vantagem em relação aos
outros todos eles não estão cá em casa
agora portanto vou treinar ver como é
que resolve treinador tirou algo muito
simples mounts embu
o que eu tenho aqui pessoal é uma bilha
de gás hélio e volto já sabe que o
cabelo né
o lateral titular e muito menos a pele a
sua vez numa edição é mesmo a minha loja
de posição ou outra mas graças à sua
luva experimentar agora o piloto duas
vezes mas joel inscrito vamos pensar num
nível mais baixo que só com copos eu vou
ter alguns copos em cima daquela mesa e
vamos tentar acertar só para ver se eu
ainda tô aqui ironizou não mas vamos ver
agora aberto não foi muito fácil muito
fácil tentar atingir uma meta vamos
tentar achar os 11 mil likes neste
diário
nós conseguimos atingir o extreme light
e vou tentar fazer um alvo em movimento
com fogo a volta não sei como vocês mas
eu vou fazer qualquer pessoa ou
experimentar agora encher o balão e
vamos ver se abala com segmentar o balão
não sou assim
eu acho que vai aumentar muito fácil é
só aqui que as garras balas e acerta em
poucos vou voltar a casar possam para
falar agora 32 bull vai
a juventus ou o meu deus é muito louco e
muito eu vou encher os olhos com ele vai
ser bem divertido porque eles vão embora
tudo lá pra cima eu vou tentar o
resultado vamos ter aqui uma piscina sem
bala em um tiroteio mais difícil
implementar um bolão porque lá tem mais
resistência eu acho que é isso
em 2000 o talento só vou fazer um teste
e vou tentar dar um tiro para cima e
vamos tentar obter bala casa mas que ela
supostamente sobe e desce o rio a nado
agora pessoalmente nos balões com ela
agora só vou voltar aqui um evangelho
que é que vai acontecer o governo vai
muito longe 321 bairro foi muito longe a
bola voltar a rolar lá é frágil e
animada
agora só vai apoiar meu metabolismo se
esqueça de acompanhar meu
não só atende os balões todos já sabem
que um saco na sede da nike barriga
também sai você que não parecem que já
atuou em dois meses a menina am em uma
cama com ela só agora vou tentar acertar
mim e 29 das pessoas não vai muito bem
agora
agora está agora está mais um balão
embora mais meu cérebro está muito
difícil esse desafio eu acho que é o
vento vem que não ajuda nada mas agora
vai mexer aqui toda a carga meu tudo
tudo tudo agora vai a 32
vai ser difícil é muito difícil dentro
do carro está muito em baixo podem ver
estão em falta de pontaria não porque
quando algo está parado
é muito fácil encontrar um domínio ou r
penas passa a lutar algodão executam
esperanças do flamengo e do estranho
fazer isso eu que sou assim não desistir
jamais vou embora vou mandar um bom tem
o cabelo e vou tentar sentado não falam
a bola só fica de costas não vou tentar
o bahia está na cabeça e acertar vai dar
muita bosta ia ser tudo costas mil
eu acho que não é isso que está a
decorrer da tarde para a porta voz por
cima lá
e depois dia do lábio e agora o
brasileiro gritou agora é evitar e jorge
henrique
rápido o que vocês querem que eu faça
vídeos para fazerem um estado basco pelo
canal lupi subscrevam a poente
exatamente o que tem mais vidas com stop
que comentem e é isso que vai até a
próxima